it's been over a year and a half since
the blame game began over the Nava chalk
attack in Salisbury and while British
officials are saying that Vladimir Putin
is likely to be behind it the man
leading the investigation into the
incident says there's no strong evidence
to prove it even though that's been
highlighted before the whole of the
investigation is still alive Criminal
Investigation in order to get a European
arrest warrant you have to have a case
capable of being charged in this country
we haven't got a case capable of being
charged you'd have to prove he was
directly involved British officials are
saying that there is a strong chance
that the Russian President Vladimir
Putin ordered two Russian spies to carry
out the attack against the former
Russian military agent sergey skripnikov
of dawn sturgis who was also exposed to
the nerve agent Navi chalk in the nearby
area however there is essentially no
proof of that and despite the lack of
strong evidence we're hearing the
official line from London has not really
changed much at all throughout the last
year and a half we know that the United
Kingdom has blamed these two Russian
spies charged them and also asked for
them to be extradited to the United
Kingdom to face these charges officially
the line from the British government of
course from the very GetGo was also
pointing the fingers of blame at Russia
is highly likely that Russia was
responsible we do hold Russia culpable
culpable culpable for the attempted
murder Russia is Cape is culpable our
quarrel is with Putin's Kremlin and it
is now time that the Russian state comes
forward and explains exactly what has
gone on it is completely unacceptable
for our people to be either deliberate
or accidental targets well Moscow
accuses the United Kingdom of shutting
down attempts to collaborate over the
investigation
however London says is Moscow that's not
willing to help out plus of course we
know that the scientists who were
working in that military Research
Laboratory of Porton Down which is
nearby Salisbury it was unable to prove
the origin of the nerve agent of Navi
shock that was used in the attack in the
meantime of course this Salisbury
incident turned into an international
saga where the United States imposed
sanctions on Russia not to mention of
course
that nearly over 20 countries worldwide
expelled Russian envoys in solidarity
with the United Kingdom so what we're
seeing is that there's no breakthrough
moment in this case at least there's no
new evidence presented from the United
Kingdom side and so the standoff is
likely to continue
you